a city councilwoman in california is
fighting back against what she says in
his extortion attempt
to shame her on the internet sonoma city
council member rachel hundley provided
these screen grabs to cbs news
she says they were part of a website
that was emailed to her
the sender threatened to make the
website public to harm her image
unless she dropped out of her
re-election race
anna warner spoke to hundley about why
she's not backing down
at first it was just utter shock rachel
hundley became one of the youngest
people ever elected to a city council
seat in sonoma california
she's now 35 and about to run for a
second term
but says about two weeks ago she got a
threatening email
as soon as i saw it i knew exactly what
they were trying to do
the email told her we believe your
behavior is immoral and unethical
we encourage you to reconsider your
intention to run for city council
it then gave the link to a website
slamming her using her own pictures
images she herself had posted to social
media mixed with what hundley describes
as blatant lies
accusations of lascivious drunk and
drug-addled behavior
it's extortion because it was demanding
that i'd do something
that was using my photos to market their
lies about me
but instead of stepping aside hundley
stepped forward
and in a youtube video told the public
she'd been threatened
its purpose is to make me afraid
to silence another strong female voice
by scaring me out of this election and
she gave their tactics a name
it was [ __ ] shaming meaning to you what
does that mean that phrase
she paused before answering
[ __ ] shaming is an attempt to use
women's sexuality against them
and it's turning it into something
negative
based solely on the thought
that it should be shameful the website
has since disappeared
her video meanwhile has gotten more than
175
thousand views women have always faced
harassment women who
try to make policy and run for office
but the exciting thing
is so frequently people like rachel
stand up and say like
butts off like back off enough so you
basically felt like you were speaking
for other women
i was my hope was that it would spread
enough
that potentially it would make its way
to other women who might fight it useful
and if i could achieve those things i
would consider it successful
whether she's successful in the election
will be determined
come november for cbs this morning anna
werner
sonoma california and we reached out to
local authorities to verify hundley's
claims they confirmed that she issued a
claim but they say it's not being
investigated because it doesn't rise to
the level of a crime
but it's good for her to kind of own
this and speak out about it i remember
recently speaking someone there's so few
women now even running for
office in college like school president
because of the shame that can come
online through social media
and that's because people shame you in a
way you know it couldn't have been easy
for her to do that but she's empowering
other people
yeah and hopefully the vermin who tried
to extort her has gone back into
whatever hole he came from
absolutely